I figured that my best bet was to turn
and run for my car then I can hopefully
make a getaway and alert the please
hello and welcome to Wang deigned a
creepypasta horror stories cooked to
perfection with a splash of red sauce my
name is Susie and I will be your server
this episode
today's portion was written to take the
Holly and jolly out of the holidays and
replaced them with hate and misery this
shocking ending will leave you
devastated let's dig right in for the
last couple of years my wife I have
hosted a Secret Santa gift exchange
during the holidays it's a very new
tradition but we thought it would be
nice to put together since a lot of our
friends can't really afford to buy gifts
for everyone we do it a little bit
differently than some people might be
accustomed to everyone randomly gets a
name and has to buy that person and gift
around fifty dollars we have one
get-together where everyone opens their
gifts but even after the swap you never
find out who gave you the gift my wife
and I agreed that that part is important
she says that what makes the holiday
special is having good faith in all of
our friends to get the person something
good in other words if you're only
buying a gift in order to get
recognition for it then the whole idea
is kind of cheapened besides these are
our friends if you can't trust them and
can you trust sure there are exceptions
where it's obvious who gave the gift
like last year when our friends Emily
and Elena who were married ended up
getting each other or also last year
when Cynthia received a cheap ice tray
is her gift from her recently ex
boyfriend mark we were optimistic that
this year would be filled with positive
which it was two at points anyway we
have a Secret Santa app that
automatically emails everyone involved
and tells them who they got it's great
because it allows us as the organizers
not to get our Secret Santa spoiled
I got Troy the newest addition to our
party this year I think I got the
perfect gift for him too every time I go
over to his apartment there's stuff
everywhere plates silverware blu-rays
it's not like he's just too lazy to
clean up after himself it just seems
like he doesn't have anywhere to put it
at all so I got him one of those knife
blocks a dish rack and a silverware
organizer that'll just cover the kitchen
but it's a start I had a feeling Troy
was going to appreciate it
the day of the gift exchange arrived we
had people drop off gifts in a pile as
they came in we all enjoyed some drinks
and snacks as we caught up with each
other for a couple of hours before
getting down to it by the time we
started to open our gifts everyone was
getting a bit jiggly my wife pointed out
that Troy seemed to have taken an
interest in her friend Cynthia which we
could both get behind because they were
the only two who were still single it
seemed like the party was alive and well
most of the gifts were really good too
and people kept up their poker faces as
far as I could tell when the present
they brought was being opened of course
there were a couple of obvious moments
like our friend James who most likely
got his own wife seeing as how she
didn't know how anyone else would have
known what she wanted this year
Marco actually ended up getting to
present somehow
couldn't figure out why I was worried
that the app had messed up and someone
was gonna end up with no presence but I
did a quick count and realized there
were 11 total presence for the 10 of us
I guess someone just wanted to make
Marcos day and get him something in
addition to buying something for their
person he ended up loving both presents
so it seems like no harm for the most
part though I just worried it was a bit
unfair to everyone else
the final present remaining came down to
my wife it was a black box wrapped in
what looked to be a plastic trash bag
and tied up in actual rope it was I'm
not gonna lie a really ugly exterior and
she had a lot of trouble opening it by
herself in fact nobody could seem to pry
the knot off of it granted we were all
kind of drunk at that point so we ended
up having to cut the thing open she
opened the box and pulled out a small
piece of paper she looked upset as she
read it then her hands started to shake
and her eyes glazed over what is it she
showed me the slip of paper there were
just a couple of words on it Santa says
you all die I quickly look inside the
box only to find there was nothing else
inside I can get kind of defensive at
times and I got pretty upset and took it
out on everyone within a couple minutes
the party was over and everyone was out
in the cold I wanted to get to the
bottom of who the hell thought this
would be funny by asking everyone who
their secret santa was and doing the
little research of my own to find out
who was lying but she insisted that it
wasn't that big of a deal and she'd
rather not ruin it for everyone still I
felt really betrayed and these were
supposed to be our friends and I
couldn't understand who would want to
hurt her like that but we were tired and
just decided to retire to bed
evening I told myself I would get her
something great to make up for it and
started brainstorming some gift ideas
but all I could think about was who
would do this I stayed awake for a while
longer trying to think of any reason
that someone would have to try to spook
us that's when I heard someone rummaging
around the house a chill went up my
spine and after being frozen in fear for
a few moments I sat up and began to
formulate a plan my wife woke up and
asked me what I was doing there's
someone in the house we stay here and
keep the door lock until I give you the
okay with that I slipped out and locked
the door behind me my blood was boiling
at this point I didn't know if this had
anything to do with the present from
earlier but all I wanted to do was find
who was behind this and bash his head in
the only issue is I couldn't hear anyone
moving around anymore it seemed that the
house was quiet I methodically checked
the entire upstairs it was empty
as I was checking the last closet I
heard a huge crash from downstairs I
sprinted fists blazing but the scene I
found in the living room
was far more horrifying than I could
have imagined the tree had been knocked
over into the fireplace
which was now on and it had begun its
burn I heard footsteps running to the
door but I knew I couldn't go after him
now in a panic I turned off the gas
fireplace and ran to the kitchen to grab
a jug of water I poured it over the tree
which was beginning to burn even more
but all I could manage to do was slowed
down the rapidly spreading fire luckily
my wife had already called 9-1-1 and the
fire department showed up before long I
was able to slow down the fire enough
until they arrived I wish I could say
that was the end of it but
worse the police showed up and
questioned us about what had done down
that evening we told the entire story
and they were particularly interested in
the app we'd used to sort the names for
the Secret Santa
the chief told us that an undercover
police officer would be on our block for
the time being and to call 911 if we had
any other disturbances he also gave me a
card a point of contact for if we had
any other information
it was nearly 4:00 a.m. at that point
and we were ready to put this
nightmarish evening behind us when I got
a call from Terry James's wife
they were both at the secrets and of
that night and I noticed a couple of
missed calls from her as well desperate
for more information I picked up but
before I could explain the mess that we
had been in she explained that she was
calling from the hospital apparently
they had been driving home from our
house when some maniac ran them off the
road she was fine but when I'm to
explain that James had been injured
pretty badly though he was expected to
make a recovery I decided that enough
was enough it was time to do a little
investigation of my own the next morning
I headed out to the spot of the crash as
Terry had described in me if I was gonna
get to the bottom of this I had to be
thorough after all as far as I knew
Terry was trying to cover up her James
guilt with that phone call I found tire
tracks going off the road but that
really only clears one of them I made a
call on over to the hospital I knew they
wouldn't share any information since
that's someone's private medical info
but I acted like a concerned family
member and asked if they'd been found I
was able to find out they both got
admitted at the same time so they were
both in the clear my next step was
finding out who they got gifts for in
the Secret Santa
which involved me showing up and asking
to see the email I had to catch them by
surprise to make sure they didn't try to
doctor anything so I knew I had Troy and
my wife had a hemily it was already
fairly obvious that James had his wife
Terry but I did find out that Terry had
Elena don't worry about keeping track of
all the names just know that my list of
suspects was narrowing I also discovered
that the person who went after them was
in a white van with
like tape over the license plate next on
my list were Emily and Elena it took me
a while to come up with an idea about
how I might prove their whereabouts but
I ended up finding a way to check on
them without either of them knowing see
every year there's this big Christmas
tree in town square everyone in the town
is encouraged to put up in ornaments of
their own and the whole thing is live
streamed for the entire month of
December they would most certainly go
past it on their way home all I had to
do was go back to last night around the
time they should have been driving home
luckily enough I was able to spot their
car on the stream well that didn't
necessarily clear both of them from what
happened at our house it did make them
innocent of running James and Terry off
the road unless they had just gotten a
second car that I don't know about but I
figured I could really at them if that
came to be the case I also had to make
the assumption that the intruder at our
house and the crazy driver that went
after our friends were related incidents
and the time frame of events seemed to
line up with that theory of course the
nasty present my wife received only
backed up this idea further I tried
getting a hold of Emily and Elena to see
who they got gifts for but neither one
of them could be reached the next and
final couple was Marco and Gina they had
taken an uber home from the party so all
I had to do was show up and ask to see
their ride history when I arrived Marco
was actually kind of upset that I was
accusing them I thought to myself this
was it it must be one of them but I
hadn't really planned for what I would
do if I'd gotten this far I didn't bring
anything to defend myself with not only
was Marco a big guy but it was two
against one
i clenched my fist behind my back and
slowly stepped away as Marco yelled at
me going on about how he was appalled
that I didn't trust him after everything
we've been through
I figured that my best bet was to turn
and run for my car then I could
hopefully make it getaway and alert the
police tension within me built as I
waited for him to make him move just
when I was ready to turn and run Gina
came up with the phone to her ear and
said that Terry was on the line and she
had just found out about the car crash
she invited me and to show me the
evidence I was looking for and stupidly
I accepted for all I knew this could
have been an act to lure me in and make
me more vulnerable still when Gina
delivered the news I thought I saw
something change in Marcos expression
like an understanding had come over him
like he realized now why I had to see
their whereabouts last night still I was
jumpy inside with her house and in my
mind I was keeping track of where they
both were at all times for my own safety
though I tried not to show it
Marco brought up there trip history on
uber and to my surprise they had gone
home after the party no doubt about it
they also showed me who their secret
santa recipients were Marco's was
Cynthia and Gina's was James I told them
I had to be on my way and headed out
where a van was pulling up to the curb
by their house as soon as I looked up at
it it haphazardly sped away down the
street I ran after it and found that the
license plate was
covered with black tape it was just like
what Terri had described to me I dialed
911 11 Oh what it just happened he was
still going after people so I knew I was
racing the clock here there were only
two suspects led Troy and Cynthia the
two singles who had been flirting at the
party I hope to god it wasn't Troy after
I'd put so much into my gift for him but
deep down I knew it was the nature of
the crime at my house pointed to it
being a male still I touched base with
my wife and told her to look into
Cynthia while I confronted him
everything was boiling down to this
Troy lived alone so I wouldn't be able
to get any info from anyone else he did
live in an apartment complex however so
there had to be a camera somewhere that
would prove he was out several hours
after the party ended I gave the police
chief a call and he agreed to send
someone out to meet me at Troy's
apartment complex with a warrant I
waited out by the office this was our
chance to nail him what was taking them
so long
as I waited around I heard a familiar
voice
it was Troy I was so stupid of course
he'd come back after nearly getting
caught back at Marcos this was not good
he knew I knew but he didn't let on to
it right away well so you can play at
that game my only choice was to play
dumb he pretended to be surprised to see
me
he always did have a good poker face I
told him that I had come to check on him
when I heard about James and Terry he
told me he had just heard this morning
and went over to the hospital to visit
James he was finally telling me
something I could believe a good move on
his part it would definitely make them
less suspicious of him but that wouldn't
work on me I'd caught him red-handed but
he knew I knew too much what was his
plan how long was he gonna play dumb all
I had to do was stall a little bit
longer I decided to press him on it I
asked him if anything weird had happened
after he had left the night before I was
hoping to trip him up with an
inconsistency in his story something
that didn't line up with the actual
timeline of the
it's all I got out of him now was that
he had gone straight home
he asked what I had done after everyone
had left and it was at that moment that
something clicked in my head he was
going to try to paint me as the villain
he knew we would be home into sleep
after the party so we would have no
alibi to prove that we hadn't gone and
run down James's car before coming back
to set our own Christmas tree ablaze in
an attempt to make ourselves look like
the victims after all we'd set up the
party
we could have structured it so that my
wife would receive the creepy note from
me he was going to try to pin it all on
me but I was one step ahead of him the
detective arrived
I told Troy he was busted but I knew it
would be a battle to prove my own
innocence as well he continued to play
dumb the detective provided the
apartment complex with a warrants and we
all sat down and watched the footage
this next part I deeply regret I'll
never be able to erase that look of
betrayal out of my mind because the
footage proved that Troy was innocent I
wish I had more time to apologize for
accusing him but I had to get a check on
my wife all signs now pointed to Cynthia
being the culprit I rushed home where my
wife informed me she had just gotten off
the phone with Cynthia's roommate
Cynthia was also innocent this didn't
make any sense we'd cleared everyone who
was at the party had we overlooked
someone was it somebody else outside of
the group we soon got our answer if
you're easily disturbed I suggest you
don't continue we got another call from
the police chief Emily and Elena we're
dead
somebody had broken down their door and
slit both of their throats leaving them
to bleed out under the Christmas tree
the killer had also slathered a message
on the carpet and blood it read was
about [ __ ] with arrows pointed up at
them I was sickened just by hearing
about this but the police had a strong
lead on who the killer might be mark
Berkley
Cynthia Zacks from last year Secret
Santa the a-hole who got her a nice tray
for a gift apparently one of the first
things the detective on our case did was
contact the developer of the Secret
Santa app he was given a master list of
everyone involved I guess we never
removed mark from the list when we added
Troy this year and the app told Troy to
get a present for mark Troy must have
thought it was supposed to be Marco
seeing as how he would have no idea who
mark even is that would also explain why
Marco ended up with two gifts then mark
must have snuck in at some point and
dropped my wife's gift into the pile it
was all starting to come together we
also found out that Mark had completely
lost his mind when Cynthia had broken up
with him a little over a year ago there
were multiple police reports of him
threatening her stalking her and
loitering outside her apartment
maybe when Mark accidentally got the
email about our Secret Santa that
somehow set him off again and he decided
to terrorize all of us everyone still in
her life everyone who's as close to her
as he wishes he could be the chief told
me that he had already sent his squad
over to Cynthia's as mark would likely
be heading over there next after having
hit every other couple at the party but
I knew that wouldn't be the case if Mark
really had snuck into the party to
deliver the fake gift he'd have seen
what went on between Cynthia and Troy
and he'd be in a furious rage he was
saving his best most brutal cold-blooded
strike for last in Cynthia was never on
his hit list I raced over the Troy's as
quickly as I could
but feared I may be too late when I
arrived to find his front door had been
left wide open I walked inside
it seemed strangely empty my heart sank
was I too late or was try even home when
Mark had arrived I called out Troy no
response mark I headed into the kitchen
where I saw that the dish rack and
silverware organizer I'd gotten him had
been put to good use
he'd finally tidied up his crazy mess of
stuff for that little moment I was glad
I was able to get him something
worthwhile but then it happened I never
heard it coming but I did see a shadow
come over me
as I noticed the other gift I had gotten
Troy the knife block but one of the
knives was missing
thanks for listening to all saints a
creepypasta your total comes out to $50
but if you like this video right now
you'll get everything you just listen to
absolutely free this episode has been
brought to you by the C's world merch
store check out the link in the
description and get these cool designs
such as Suzy's world and kill C's World
Cafe and more remember to subscribe to
see ZZZ world for new Horrors every week
bring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]